let's pull out this story from the post
millennial Hamas leader says the same
type of racism that killed George Floyd
is being used by Israel against the
Palestinians where is that quote I want
to I want to hear
theoy
Floy
right that makes Israel the the Derek
Chauvin of the world they Floy I I you
know what I I all right if that's his
argument I agree George Floyd was
chewing on a speedball behind the wheel
of a car the police officers were trying
to stop him because what he was doing
could result in the death of children
and himself he begged to be released
from the car and then was placed on on
the ground with a lethal amount of
various drugs in his system officers
were trying to subdue him as he was
screaming and resisting eventually he
ended up dying now should they have had
their their shovin had his knee on his
back for nine plus minutes maybe not
maybe they should have got no they
shouldn't have he should have gotten a
medical attention immediately the dude
was dying presumably due to well I think
the official reporting is that it was
Cardiac Arrest due to pressure but let's
just say the dude had a this is also a
fact he had lethal amounts of I think
Fentanyl and other drugs in a system
including meth mhm so if this guy is
arguing that they're just like George
Floyd it's like okay so you're saying
that you're like chalk full of crazy
crazy as drugs and you're engaging in
behaviors that's putting yourselves and
others at risk and now Israel is trying
to stop you from doing that doesn't work
the way you thought it here's the
argument should George Floyd have been
allowed to have chew a speedball and
drive an SUV certainly not no police
should the police have made an attempt
to stop him from doing it yeah what do
you think you're more libertarian oh man
what was happening when that went down
he was sitting behind the wheel of the
SUV presumably in a drug deal what we
thing happened is that when the cops
came up he started chewing on the
speedball spit it on on the floor crazy
amount of drugs in the system they
removed him from the vehicle and ask
them to sit down then they were going to
bring them to their SUV for an arrest
should they have done that or should
have they just should they have just
said just stay in the vehicle and do
your drugs if they have probable cause
they pull them out
so the problem with the George Floyd
story then is they handled it
irresponsibly when they when they held
him on the ground absolutely in the in
the body cam footage George Floyd is
saying put me on the ground put me on
the ground put me on the ground over and
over again and so they agree to chovin
shows up later not knowing what's going
on and then puts his knee his knee is
around the neck and the upper back uh
it's widely disputed they then call uh
medical which arrives no nine or so
minutes later in the def in the in the
in the criminal trial for Chauvin the uh
uh use of force expert for the
prosecution said chovin used a lower
amount of force than was
authorized locking up locking him up was
clearly political he was authorized to
actually tase George Floyd which is an
escalation of force and chose not to
yeah what he did still the wrong Force
it's still the wrong Force it's less
Force but it's dangerous and
irresponsible put your KN knee on
someone's neck that's the argument was
it's disputed whether or not it was
actually on his neck or not sure it like
was it was it on his back so the issue
is if someone is engaging in behavior
that could result in death are you to
blame if you engage in actions that try
to stop them from committing violent
acts so if a guy I say has a gun and
he's on drugs and he's and he's holding
that gun yeah and he's waving it around
yeah and then you tell him to drop it
and then he staggers about Falls over
and then you're like hey man this guy's
going to shoot somebody then he raises
the gun up at you and you shoot him
should you go to jail I just don't think
it's comparable to what's going on over
there you know unfortunately this Hamas
leader just totally shot himself in the
foot with this awful argument well his
his but this is my point the argument
being made by Hamas is that they are
drug addicts engaging in extremely
dangerous behavior that will kill others
and themselves and Israel is trying to
stop them well but he mostly said it
just to invoke sympathy white people but
I'm going give it to him I'm going to
give it to him you're going to give it
to him well I think it's unfortunate
that everyone in Palestine is getting
caught up his awful awful argument what
if the people in Palestine I don't know
like rose up and like captured and
arrested all of the Hamas people and
said stop doing this that would be
amazing why aren't they doing that I
think they're terrified of
Hamas vote for and some of them I mean
when liby on the other day she was
saying one of the things Hamas did was
offer social services so some people
have a relationship with Hamas that at
one point was in some ways positive even
if the things they're doing now are
negative it's a very complicated
relationship some of them I'm sure are
deeply resentful and also feel tied to
it it's like a it's like a battered
battered husband battered wife
relationship probably someone over there
is is essentially held hostage and there
are ultimately always going to be
Palestinians who feel as though Israel
is in the wrong for being there at all
absolutely even if they're not sympath
to us they don't want to dispute the
land they feel entitled to yeah one of
the first things I saw after the initial
air strike uh after Israel's first uh
initial air strike was that it was the
picture oddly enough of uh it says this
is what it looked like after Israel um
dropped bombs on Gaza and he says just
kidding this is Minneapolis after the
George Floyd riots in 2020 so that
actually ties those together even more
yeah because it looked almost the same
because Minneapolis was a destroyed as
the same way that we might know the
names of you know some random people
that come out of social movements in
other countries I really just think that
there is no understanding of the
implications of what invoking George
Floyd mean other than it makes leftists
in America sympathetic to your cause
because they believe it's a racial
argument um in fact all the leftists in
America probably have no idea what the
new on situation is they just know there
are certain sides you're supposed to
fall on and they're they're attempting
to we don't really fully understand what
it's like to vote in an election where
part of your the dominant faction of
your government is essentially a
terrorist organization what are the
implications of arguing against them
what how what happens when you come out
vocally against Hamas in Palestine
that's not something that we really
understand over here actually a lot of
them probably would say that about the
American government right they they
would actually say that like they would
say that about every time we vote for an
election here in America we're voting
for a terrorist faction they would say
that about us that's what I'm saying
like they would they would take that
position the same way that people here
are taking that position when they talk
about Palestinians voting for you know a
big difference here though is that when
our when our government engages in
atrocities it's overseas it's not in
like Mexico at least not yet you know we
haven't we haven't elected anyone yet
who's saying that they're going to go to
war in Mexico although we we should man
because the border is weak we should not
go to do we want Palestine and like Gaza
I'm just kidding although I do think we
should secure the Border I mean there is
obvious uh Conflict at the border and
there is obviously a level that you
could be classified as an invasion and
we don't do anything about it in fact we
are only interested right now in
spending money abroad in Ukraine in
Israel in in Palestine and although
humanitarian you want to offer support
to those who are suffering especially
those you might consider your ally we
are not ultimately putting the people of
Texas of Arizona and the after that
Hawaii also the Northern war is
extremely poor it's gotten worse and
worse and worse so people of Upstate New
York people of Vermont people of Maine
we put them last in this scenario and
that's ultimately The Bu government's
biggest failing in this situation that's
the most annoying part like Hawaii
wasn't that long ago like are are our
attention spans and our memories that
short that uh in between you know our
ninth funding of Ukraine and what
happened between Israel and Palestine is
that we had several things East
Palestine here all sorts of things are
happening here that are tax dollars what
did they get $700 in Hawaii per
household or something not even per
person not even right so like there's
plenty of things that our tax dollars
could be used here in America and I
think that that does resonate with the
average person I'd like to believe that
the average person who's saying like
look I just want to see the the less
nuanced position of like I just want
everybody I'm voting for peace I want
peace what they also mean is like like
need to focus on what's going on here
there's plenty to do here and I don't
think that's even like people are
calling that isolationism I don't think
it's isolationism it's just purely
trying to to make something happen your
issue is isolationism bad is totally
isolationism would mean that we're not
engaging in free trade having diplomacy
exactly which why is saying it's not
isolation doesn't always a the thing is
we just do crazy things when we're on
the global stage we're not consistent
and I just don't know not that I think
we shouldn't engaged in free trade but
ultimately the idea that we have to be
involved in everything everywhere all
the time does not serve the American
people just a hint a whisper of
isolationism please and well and they
like look if you're going to uh help
somebody else you have to help yourself
first you need to like on a plane we're
not going
to secure your mask first before you
help someone else we can do with helping
ourselves first but I but I think what
many people fail to realize is that this
argument is is essentially like the
chickens and the chicken C complaining
that we only buy certain feed and why
are we spending money outside of the
chicken coop we take their eggs they're
paying their taxes and then they're like
hey you realize the people who run this
show are wasting our food and resources
on other houses and other chicken coops
like what's this all about you know the
chickens have no Authority their say
means nothing so we sit here and we're
like the American people are upset about
what's going on bro since the end of
World War II International interests
have been have superseded us interests
the purpose of of the Petro dollar the
inter monetary fund visa and MasterCard
what the American people want is
immaterial to what the massive
International institutions are trying to
do and what they want I hope more and
more people shift their buying power
their savings out of the US dollar and
into Bitcoin we I think that we need to
starve the banks uh oh Elizabeth War's
going to put you on a list I
know yeah but maybe they want Bitcoin
well they don't get it that's just not
how Bitcoin works that's how other
cryptocurrency might work they can get
into that but in Bitcoin well why why
not what do you think well you can't
print Bitcoin into Oblivion buy it all
oh can you other people own it right you
buy from them we don't know who all owns
it so the US government when when if
they're really concerned about Bitcoin
look I like Bitcoin I think bitcoin's
good I have Bitcoin but if the US
government's really concerned about
Bitcoin with $33 trillion in debth yeah
they could buy out Bitcoin I don't know
about that I think that was good that's
the the only way they couldn't is that
some people would not sell there you go
but that's not enough there's a lot of
people who really really hate the US
dollar who own a lot of Bitcoin there's
a lot of wealthy people in Dubai who
have a lot of Bitcoin too and see in the
interest of the United States to buy as
much Bitcoin as possible but they're not
doing it they want they're they're
they're too hubristic they're too htic
perhaps but I kind of think they they
would and this is the argument that I
made to a bunch of my Anarchist and
libertarian friends if you were a uh say
like a Council on Foreign Relations or
something like that mhm you believed in
some kind of like liberal economic order
you're trying to create so that you
could control the flow of currency
around the world what you what you need
is a universal trade Med the US dollar
is great but doesn't penetrate literally
everywhere we do pretty well with it
right so you want a One World Currency
you want everyone using the same
currency well how do you go about doing
that every time you bring up something
like a multinational currency or an
international currency all these
crackpot conspiracy theorists
Libertarians and anarchists start losing
their minds I got an idea what if we
seed them into promoting our Universal
Global Currency and get them to be the
ADV advocates for it there's an idea so
the first thing we'll do is we will
create a digital currency that tracks
everything you do so we'll know every
purchase you make we'll we'll be able to
track it publicly and openly you won't
be able to hide it because bit it's not
it's not Monero it's not zcash it's
Bitcoin and then what we'll do is we'll
go to all the Libertarians and tell them
hey this is anti-government money
Meanwhile we're the on secretly hold in
the bulk of it and they won't be able to
track it because we have the machines
and we know the plan and they don't then
you get a bunch of Libertarians being
like I'm going to buy this up they get
really wealthy off of it start
advocating for it to be the thing to buy
but Bitcoin if you're using it for
transactions everything you do is
tracked
publicly that's surveillance State 101
but it's so safe Tim everyone's so safe
look I like Bitcoin I like Bitcoin
there's a lot of great things about it I
like crypto in general I don't like
crypto in general I think that it opens
the door for Central Bank digital that's
I I was joking about being safe isn't
safe for the government they're taking
care of us think there's a big
difference between Bitcoin and and
general definit there is but the main
challenge with Bitcoin is that
everything you do is publicly tracked
and the government will always know
every purchase you've ever made and they
want to get rid of cash and it's
Libertarians advocating for switching
over to a completely digital currency
that is tracked by the government no no
no no no no no no I'm not advocating for
switching over completely I'm saying we
need say I'm saying the Libertarians are
the massively advocating for well sure I
mean i' say the Liber party has the
official position that everybody should
adopt Bitcoin but it's overwhelmingly
the Libertarians who who made Bitcoin
successful it's good I'm holding out I
don't think it's the government I think
that this is this is a smart move and we
need to diversify and get off the US do
you think the Bitcoin is accessible to
the average American meaning
like what kind of financial literacy do
you need to have to be able to get into
Bitcoin CU I think there are a lot of
people who get a fair they hear these
stories about malfunctions or whatever
else and they get scared of Bitcoin I
think probably a good eight hours of
learning about it that's more than we
get in high school in America just a
good a good eight hours and you probably
could figure out how to use it safely do
you think that everybody should be using
it as their day-to-day currency not yet
but eventually maybe we need to we need
to make it easier to use lightning
Network and things like that not there
yet aren't those components of it more
centralized though and run by like big
Tech Guys in Silicon Valley no no that
no I don't think that people should be
using major uh trading platforms if that
if that makes sense I think people need
to be a little bit safer when they use
it the challenge is the reason why
Bitcoin forked so many times is because
large portions of the community disagree
with each other and and it's it's direct
democracy so what happens is 51% of the
people running Bitcoin decide a rule
change comes into effect and then just
boot out the other 49 who now still will
have that forked currency but that
creates Bitcoin cash and like you know
all these other derivatives of Bitcoin
because people disagree with the the
changes being implemented by the
majority it's okay that there's some
choice in currency sure yeah uh that's
why I think bitcoin's good but I don't
know if I believe in this like total
Bitcoin world I don't I don't don't get
me wrong I don't think it needs to be
total Bitcoin world I think this is a
good way to push back against the US
dollar but so so so what what world is
that is that some of the trade we do is
in Bitcoin some of it is in
I think well it doesn't even necessarily
have to be US Dollars you're going to
have to push off of the dollar and push
against it and see what happens what do
you trade with right now you've got
Bitcoin people are also they still have
gold and silver you know there are gold
bugs out there I'm not so you're not
trading with gold and silver right the
the value of gold and silver is too
great based on it weight so you could do
the gold backs for instance but then
it's just like people look at your side
i' like you're giving me a polymer
enclosed gold foil bill is this let's
move the pirates and their deons I more
on to bitcoin and see what happens with
the dollar my biggest concern is weaken
the Federal Reserve uh and I I agree
with that but my concern about Bitcoin
is that you're the government will be
able to track everything you do I think
it's a little Doomer they can already
track everything we do yeah but not when
you buy things in cash or at the very
least depends on how large of a
transaction it is in cash yeah even then
because going into a bank it's being
tracked and and Banks aren't even giving
out certain deposits but uh you know if
you go buy something even 10 grand in
cash it's
you have a choice of whether you're
following the law or not like my
attitude is like just pay your taxes but
there is a bit more leeway in so I'll
put it this way Moxy Marlin Spike made a
great point about why why some there
needs to be room for people to commit
illegal acts yeah and the argument he
made was
marijuana everybody right now is
starting this is years ago I interviewed
him he said people are start we're
starting to see the legalization of
recreational and medicinal marijuana but
how would people know they wanted it
legal if they never tried it there has
to be a little bit of give in the system
otherwise it only Flows In One Direction
and I'm like that's actually completely
correct if things become illegal and
then you are prevented from ever seeing
it or hearing or touching it eventually
we all live in Gray boxes we don't own
anything and everything's illegal there
has to be a way to push back and test
the boundaries and be like wait wait
actually this shouldn't be illegal so
the challenge with Bitcoin is that I see
everything you do will be completely
tracked and is and not just by the
government but by any other nefarious
actors and foreign governments well you
can use Monero if you're uncomfortable
with Bitcoin so that's why I like crypto
not just Bitcoin Bitcoin Bitcoin itself
is good so much out there that's so bad
though in yeah but that's like saying
you know I bought a you know uh pyite
and it turned out not to have been gold
I got scammed it's like okay well you
know someone scammed you yeah that
doesn't mean gold is bad you know so
crypto I like I think we agree yeah
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net